In 1588, Elizabeth's navy
defeated the Spanish armada
in the greatest English victory since Agincourt.
The celebrations were long
and magnificent.
The procession to the thanksgiving service
at St Paul's Cathedral was the grandest
since Elizabeth's coronation. The captured Spanish banners
were hung up as trophies
and a commemorative medal was struck
with the inscription 'God's winds blew,
and they were scattered.' And the English
really thought that God had fought on their side.
They were the new chosen race,
God's own Protestant people.
England stood proud, and Elizabeth
and her reign were at their zenith.
It was the golden age of Elizabethan England.
The great houses Elizabeth's courtiers built
are a visible, tangible expression
of their confidence, exuberance,
and wealth.
Unlike her father, King Henry VIII,
Elizabeth built no palaces. Nothing.
She'd no need to, because
her courtiers and favourites built for her.
Sir Christopher Hatton, the Lord Chancellor, already had
a great house at Holdenby.
But he told Elizabeth he would build another one
nearby at Kirby, that would be dedicated to her
as a shrine to a holy saint.
Elizabeth had ceased to be
a mere queen and she'd become